yo your album is amazing man thank you
man I think it's your best body of work
yes it's really cool it's old to me
already yeah
yeah I know four years yeah the whole
pandemic me Instagram is working on it
and
you know so it's old to me but always on
release day I always sit in the car and
listen to it and for some reason it
sounds brand new to me and I was like yo
this is a solid body of work I'm proud
of it yeah uh I mean shout out to
Ghostface Killah who [__] showed up
and showed out I think everybody that
gave me a verse on there like everybody
they showed up Chic Louch two yeah uh
track three yeah Rise of the Silver I
couldn't have an album with Silverback
without cheek of course yeah gun play
pottied it kill it you got gun place
saying [__] your life facts I love it
facts did you guys hang out
nah we we plan to and then I feel like
it'd be a fun hang me too okay I would
like just like to go do something random
with Gunplay like go to escape room or
something no I would love to have gun
play in Coney Island yeah because it's
like it's on the Block yeah bro get him
a chopped cheese yeah it'll be hilarious
it would be hilarious Yo I haven't
talked to you since well on the podcast
since I actually went to Coney Island
and like um when you say you run Coney
Island like uh
yeah it's true so like if anybody ever
like questions that like just go there
and you'll be like oh I see this [__]
G everywhere facts and then you just
like walk in and like just take [__] out
of the store and they're like you're
fine but I mean that's
that's what the mayor does the mayor of
Coney Island facts yo this [__] fly
dog it's this one fly the whole bro
earlier today I took my hat off in the
interview and I try to [__] nail it
yo you got to freeze them out bro this
don't even got you don't got no AC on
man that's over there it's over there
and it's loud oh that's why there's AC
right there up there you gotta freeze
them out if you put the AC on bro
they'll get Frozen and he'll try to get
out I just want to shoot him in the face
yeah yeah
um no but the uh the the album is great
man so you do I text you you delivered
you delivered
um always good on the first album of a
three album deal you know what I'm
saying for sure everybody happy I wasn't
asking now that you're working with uh
with Paul Rosenberg who's obviously uh
for people who don't know he's a
legendary uh executive who also has been
managing Eminem his whole career and was
a former head of Def Jam and has Goliath
uh what what how did this whole I mean
the one thing I love about Paul and M is
when they sign artists they just sign
artist they like [__] with facts it
ain't about the cloud it ain't about the
metrics it's like yo I [__] with what
you're doing
let's see if we can add to that yeah
like they did that with Griselda like
I'm saying for so for you what was the
initial like linkage between y'all and
like tell me about that relationship so
he started following me
I would say maybe a year and a half ago
two years ago as soon as he started
following me I DM them Yo management
this is before I had my team set up yeah
um he was like y'all [__] what you're
doing any way I could help I got you but
uh I'm not managing nobody no more I'm
done with that I don't got the time or I
don't want I think he used to manage
action right he managed map I think
Blink 182 I was mad people [__] so um
so basically fast forward I'm doing the
album with scram and scram when the
album we thought it was done he was like
yo let's play it for Paul I'm like
you got to connect he's like yeah he's
on shift 45 yeah
and Paul sat down listen to the album
and he [__] with it and was just like
yo
um give me
a couple months I got y'all I was like
all right that's that's good enough for
me yeah yeah I waited we waited that was
in like September waited to November he
was like give me to January wait it's
January he was like yo I got you it was
just taking long right right right right
right so it took maybe almost a year but
it was worth a man of his word
absolutely three album deal yep
Goliath slash virgin and then you had
had some sort of like uh chance with M
back in the day too right like after we
talked about it a bit
uh they was trying to develop me as the
artist for shady I never met him but I
was [__] with D12 rest in peace proof
yeah
um
but uh Riggs Morales was the a r up
there and he would bring me up there all
the time and they you know they wanted
to develop me as one of the artists did
Paul like remember that or was he even
aware of that so they pull I found out
you now that he kind of like blackballed
me from the from the office because I
wrote
[__] your life on their door nem's
[__] life in my mind I'm like this is
fire because everybody that walks into
this building now is gonna see nem's
[__] your life I'm gonna think of me
like when you did it in Compton exactly
exactly yo and I did it in Def Jam years
before right right right right deal with
them at 17 but theirs was worse I was in
their bathroom bro I wrote it in the
mirror on the bathroom and Mark I don't
I look back now I'm like
[__] what was wrong with me bro but um
yeah so so he was like y'all told
everybody in the office don't [__] with
you once you did that I was like don't I
don't want this kid coming nowhere near
this building so you know years later
now you're with him absolutely that's
dope how has it been he's I mean it's
been amazing Paul is uh
mad he's like us yeah and you know you
know you just hear his name throughout
the years and you know you build it
becomes like a myth but for sure oh he's
just like us I was just talking about
[__] I had Thurston how the third on the
show
I think I sent that to Paul
and I was like yo Paul you got bars yeah
and he was like yeah he was like yeah
thirsting how shout out to the low lives
he was like yeah man Rosenberg used to
be rapping in [__] in Brooklyn yeah
and Brownsville yeah yeah Paul said yo
me and M would take the train to
Brownsville crazy in the early days and
go and run I've been going to
Brownsville in the 90s facts yo you
don't want you don't want to go to
Brownsville right now yeah right now so
in the 90s it's like bro but that's also
a testament to who Thurston Howell is
you know he's well respected
super solid dude um but yeah I sent that
clip to Paul and I was like yo how come
I didn't know it he's like yeah Paul
Bunyan was my rap name sick name and
also like visually makes sense bro he's
mad too he's like Paul Bunyan facts for
sure shout out to Paul Bunyan man
um for you like I know how big of a deal
it is to have Ghostface on the record
and have a relationship with Ghostface
and have them sit down in the cold on
your podcast like
I know that's a huge deal for you
um bro then I tell you the Ghostface
verse was some [__] vintage Ghost
Face [__] yes you did the verse is crazy
sounds like [__] Enter the 36
Chambers oh my God it's so good man like
I just think it's like I I just think
it's dope to kind of just see like
your your grind like just paying off bro
nah absolutely and ghost he was just at
um we had a release party last Thursday
the night before it dropped he was there
he pulled up pulled up yo super solid
bro super solid like he
like he's really tuned in too he's
tapped in with you know you see these
artists you grow up listening to these
people and you're just like
yo this [__] flying is crazy bro this
fight is mad aggressive yo busy if you
see the fly over there kill that
[__] bro
bro I need you to just take something
and hit it go give him a weapon give him
a hardeen hat
give him the hard Dean hat we need a
weapon I'm gonna kill this [__]
fly this cockamani bastard it's right up
there it's on the other side of the
pillar oh you don't got no spray bro
what am I gonna [__] rate us out in
here we're in a small room you wanted me
to rate it right there yeah there you go
yeah just hit him with the [__] King
Palm tray bro
[__] ass fly got me [__] up 100 you
killing with that
they used to give it to you now but you
were saying uh so Ghostface came to the
release party release pause yo he's just
super solid bro he's he's I gotta he's
like he's like around five or six all
the time for me in my personal list we
went through this [__] Supreme Clientele
one of the best hip-hop albums ever made
yeah I think if you like roll in like
Iron Man
obviously only Built for Cuban links in
his presence on that album he said on my
podcast he don't like Iron Man
he don't like the the his album Iron Man
could it could it be that do you think I
was gonna say I I somehow think liquid
sword somehow does it is like the most
somehow become the most underrated
Wu-Tang album ever because I feel like
it always gets like [__] yes like
trumped when people talk about like only
Built for Cuban links or 36 Chambers I'm
like I don't know Liquid Swords Liquid
Swords is amazing I just recently went
back and listened to it front to back so
[__] good man amazing album and it
does you're absolutely right I think
that's also because jizz is just very
he's very reserved yeah he's an
introvert he didn't have a big
personality as absolutely as the other
guys absolutely that might be it too
yeah I think that's a lot of it too
shout out to the reason man you ever tap
in with a risen no I met him recently
um but I never tapped him with him like
musically which it would be a dream come
true for sure absolutely I also feel
like he doesn't do a lot so be like if
you get a recipe exactly exactly what
are we doing here thanks see that's like
like mugs like mugs
he posted I don't have to be a year ago
now but he posted one day like yo I just
found mad old dad tapes from the 90s of
my Beats whoa I hit him immediately like
yo
send me some joint he sent me recently
he sent me like you're supposed you're
supposed to come on my show soon he's
got an album coming out yeah yeah he's I
texted the guy back on my bucket of this
[__] please bring him by and I and we're
I think we're like neighbors because he
walks his dog on my street all the time
and I've never stopped and been like
yo mugs why because I just think it'd be
super weird bro the mugs has an ill
Mystique about him bro in his studio is
like in our neighborhood so stupid it's
in Burbank because it looks like it
because when we would just come here I
was like this Mike's Studio I could walk
there in like six minutes from my front
door okay it's just this black building
next to this popular Mexican restaurant
and it just the soul assassins A's on it
and I remember I hit my boy I'm like yo
it's mug studio in Burbank yeah it's
right there on Victory I was like yeah
that's crazy yeah right legendary [__]
and when you go bro it's like a time
machine in there he got oh like well
once I interview him I'm gonna try to I
Wanna my goal is to become friends so we
can like walk our dogs together
and then I can be like hey man can I
come and check the studio man yo that
that's that studio I recorded that last
time I was out here I was like bro this
[__] is like so you guys five Beats from
them from the dats from the that's the
old joints some of them are not even
complete
I'll finish it up that's fire I got you